hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my arrow episode 11 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet we have to talk about
all kinds of Black Canary Talia all gold
stuff so right off the bat if he didn't
catch the end of the episode she says
her name is really Dinah Drake the
original version of the Black Canary
from the Golden Age comics her daughter
became Dinah Laurel Lance so I feel like
they averted a giant fandom landmine
like people were already upset because
what was going on with Laurel but then
they saw that this new Black Canary was
coming in and she wasn't from the comics
how dare they but turns out that was a
fake name so I am so happy with the way
this went down in celebration of that
there's a new round of the injustice to
give away I'm giving away copy of the
game all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment about the
episode on this video and just a
reminder that giveaway winners are
announced at the end of videos I get a
lot of weird questions about that
sometimes so I'll explain what's going
on with Dinah Drake what the TV show is
probably going to do with her because
it's not going to be so easy it's not
immediately going to start being Black
Canary but the Talia al Ghul stuff will
come back in present-day as well so top
10 WTF in comic book Easter eggs there
were a lot of them so the beginning of
the episode is sort of the origin of the
Teena Boleyn character as we know her we
didn't learn her real name to the end of
the episode that's what everyone was
screaming so we see that she was in
Central City we learned that she was an
undercover cop trying to take down Sona
who's actually a character from the
comics I'll explain in a second but
basically it's a drug ring she was
trying to take down so she was there the
night of the particle accelerator
explosion so she got metahuman powers
she's screaming so she basically has
sonic abilities in number 9 as we learn
her real name is Dinah Drake the
original Golden Age version of The Black
Canary so what ended up happening is is
that later in the comics during the
Silver Age they made it a
mother-daughter thing so her daughter
became the Dinah Laurel Lance character
so when most people think of Green Arrow
Black Canary being together in the
comics being a couple
that's the Dinah Laurel Lance version of
the character the daughter of the Golden
Age Black Canary but in the Golden Age
comics during the Justice Society
be braving the bull team up she actually
meets the green arrow and they develop a
relationship so even the Golden Age
version of the character was in love
with that version of green arrow but you
have to remember that they retcons stuff
as they get to the Silver Age
there's crisis on Infinite Earths so the
modern version that most of you have
been reading this whole time is the
younger daughter version of the
character the way they set her character
up is relatively comic-book accurate she
was a police detective on the TV show in
the comics Dinah Drake was trained by
her father to become a police detective
but he ends up getting killed and she's
denied entry to the police academy so
she takes it upon herself to become a
vigilante so the arrow versions of
character is actually pretty comic-book
accurate but number eight you can kind
of see with her backstory that it's a
mirror for Oliver's backstory he spent
his time on the island she had her own
version of the island which was like her
undercover work that's crucible that she
had to survive she is sort of like
season 1 Oliver right now with her own
version of the list that's what her
vision board of death and revenge looks
like it's basically Oliver's list so in
the way that he's come this far since
that original version of himself the
hood which I'll talk about in a second
too because we get to see the season 1
costume again and the season 1 bow she's
still in super stabby mode and that's
just their way of showing you that it's
not going to be so easy like they aren't
just going to roll up offer her
membership and she's going to be like ok
I don't want revenge for my partner's
death anymore so what kind of like the
way they're taking their time in getting
her to actual Black Canary because she
hasn't taken up the mantle yet she just
said that she's in for her second chance
number 7 was the felicity storyline the
way they explained it is the Diggle
freedom would come at the cost of
felicity so she's sort of selling out to
this darker crowd I know they made it
seem kind of cheerful but she's actually
going to be doing some pretty hardcore
illegal stuff so she's still trying to
do good things this season but it's just
going to take her down a very dark path
and when they say dark they mean
interesting so she'll be doing a lot of
really cool stuff that's what the
Pandora program was it was basically a
program for opening up all this
information on really bad companies
really bad people and it might even end
up causing some collateral damage
usually when one
the heroes inside the team does
something really dark and make some big
win usually it comes at some great price
so we just haven't seen the price that
Felicity is going to have to pay to have
all this power number six
Oliver finally gets to meet Talia it
doesn't sound like he totally
understands where she comes from she
makes some jokes about her age like her
longevity the fact that she's very young
she trained Yao Fei is something of a
family secret that he'll learn about
when he gets involved with the League of
Assassins later in life as we've seen in
previous seasons so in the comics Talia
is older than Nyssa I totally think they
can do some Talia versus Nyssa in a
future episode if Katrina law becomes
available because she's part of the
training day TV show now she's a series
regular so she's just unavailable for
arrow so I think that opened the door
for them to bring Talia on the show but
she's sort of setting Oliver on the path
in the first big test is taking down
this human trafficker who's giving kovar
all this money so it's all just a big
reminder of who Oliver is he's running
from the person that he needs to be
she's trying to remind him of that that
he has a purpose in that purpose is the
list number five was all the big belly
burger this wasn't as much of a WTF it
was just like a really fun Easter Egg
because in season one they actually had
a big belly burger set where they shot a
lot of scenes so when people say that
arrow season five is going back to its
season one roots in the way it tells
stories the things that it does it is
very literally going back to some big
season one things including number four
the original season one costume in the
season one bow with the message that
Oliver reads at the beginning of each
episode where Talia says you need to
become something else someone else
that's Stephen Amell voiceover at the
beginning of every single episode so the
whole thing here is that this is the
last big step is Oliver trains to go
back to Star City and start crossing
names off the list so I'll talk about
the flashbacks at the end of this
because even though this is the last
season of these type of flashbacks
they're still going to use flashbacks
when they're necessary for adding
context of scenes but it's not going to
be as big as they've been in the past
number three is the sonís villain which
is kind of like the black Canary's
version
of Kovar like I said she and Oliver have
this parity between their storylines
where she's trying to defeat her big
boss while Oliver is trying to defeat
his in the flashbacks and just like
Oliver during season one you know she's
kind of like a season 1 version of
Oliver she kills him at the end of the
episode but he is a comic book character
that was created by Andrew Kreisberg
who's the showrunner on the flash he
actually wrote the Green Arrow comic for
a while so the sona's character is just
a sonic villain that goes up against
green arrow and black Canary during that
run so I always love it when they do
comic book characters but it's even more
fun when the characters were created by
actual people that are working on the
shows right now number two was the
world's quickest flash crossover bargain
I'm teased this he said don't blink or
you'll miss it it was just that funny
moment where they're sitting in the bill
belly burger and Oliver has to prove who
he is the captain sing I wouldn't be
surprised if they do little crossovers
like this in the future but we're
heading into sweeps week like we have
the gorilla city episode on the flash so
they tend to do the biggest things
around sweeps weeks so if there's going
to be a big crossover to be had or fun
moments like this they'll time them very
carefully just to get people really
crazy and hyped up in number one
speaking of hyped up the reveal that
she's actually Dinah Drake so it was a
nice twist at the end of the episode
I like the actress I like the character
I like the way they gave you to explain
her for her across the episode how she
sort of like tracks down all these
villains she's a total badass she's a
former police detective they explained
that she has all the skills and she has
the command of her abilities that is
needed of someone to operate on Team
arrow so that aside everyone was really
upset because they're like we want a
metahuman Black Canary and we want it to
be like black siren because she was the
closest we got to a Green Arrow Black
Canary scene from the comics but when
they announced the character's name was
Tina Bowen everybody just got really
upset people were really upset last week
about the Laurel stuff about the new
black Canary steps but tonight when they
dropped that bomb at the end of the
episode oh that was only my cover name
my real name is Dinah Drake the original
version of The Black Canary everyone was
really excited there's always going to
be people that are upset for weird
or they really like the actress and they
want her to come back but the way they
explain it is that she is almost beyond
redemption so she's probably going to
still be evil when they bring her back
on but now they can do Black Canary
versus black siren whenever she comes on
it'll be a lot of fun so let me know
what was your favorite moment from the
episode what do you think about the new
Black Canary so far and she hasn't
really picked up the name yet
so it's probably going to be a couple
more episodes before they explain how
that's going to work so either way I
feel like it was a great move for the
show I always wanted them to do a
metahuman Black Canary the easiest way
to do that was to use the particle
accelerator explosion and really cool
just to get you hyped up for next week
they're going to Russia in present day
team arrow is going to Russia the last
time they were there I think was during
season 2 so it'll be a lot of fun so
everybody make sure you watch next week
- congratulations to the new flash ring
giveaway winner Swift
anima please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details I'll name that injustice
- giveaway winner the next time I post a
DC video so I got some Marvel some Star
Wars coming tomorrow they'll be Game of
Thrones probably some new DC this
weekend but if you have requests for
arrow flash bonus videos stuff that
happened this week on the TV shows just
leave them in the comments below while
you guys wait for this post you can
click here for my black slash legends of
tomorrow and you can click here for the
flash episode thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you in the next video